men's semis were yesterday baylor rolled
into the title game routing houston
but it was ucla and gonzaga providing
fans with the excitement check it out
final seconds
of the overtime right here
that there
oh what a game what a shot you won't
find a better national semi
um bulldogs they win it they advance
what a crazy half court shot to win that
thing
i got as many dribbles as i can you know
try to get as close as i could
um he was actually like right under me
by me i just put it up
i was fading away with it and dude it
went off the backboard and then and
i don't know i've always wanted to run
up on the table and you know like call
me and d
wade and and go like that and i mean
that's the first thing i did but
man uh that that's something that you
practice you know on your mini hoop
as a kid or in a gym just messing around
and to come out with a win i mean i know
we had a
lucky half quarter at the end but both
teams
battled battled and and and dug as deep
i think as they they could and and uh
uh man hats off to ucla they are
really really really good and just so so
well coached
wow what an exciting game so it's
top-ranked gonzaga and baylor fighting
for the crown on monday
it'll be only the second time in history
that two teams ranked in the top three
all season
will meet for the national title the
last and only other time was in 1962
cincinnati beat ohio state
hey don't forget that game coming up
right here on channel 8 monday 6 o'clock
bulldogs
are four and a half point favorites